[Music]
my name is van Cunha I'm one of the
techniques bringing Chrome OS know
Android to Chrome OS very funny with me
today is Sarah and Emily and we are
telling you a lot about accessibility on
Android applications on Chromebooks so
on with that well you had that one first
of who of you did any kind of work
bringing your applications into the
accessibility room
did anyone awesome well you know what
you are possibly already done but you
don't have to leave now please stay we
have actually some more things which
might be of interest for you so and
therefore we have hopefully some good
tidbits for you so first of all if this
is one of the questions for the rest of
the folks why should you care about
accessibility
well it's a very good question right
well within the US for example one out
of eight people have a kind of a
disability that is a shocking big number
right so the thing is like if you do not
really address this in your applications
you will actually miss out on a lot of
people or look at it like a non
worldwide scale according to world
healthy organizations there is 15% of
people which do not really well which
have some kind of disability and
possibly some problems with your
applications if you do not access that
there is a big number so and then comes
the very interesting part which nobody
really thinks about that is temporal
disabilities there is something like
what everybody has everyday when I'm
coming into the office in the morning
and I'm not really that awake and I'm
looking at the screen at the font is
teeny-tiny I will possibly use a zoom in
order to zoom it up a little bit which
is already an accessibility feature in
itself so in over the course of the day
I might actually revert everything and
make it actually that the font is
getting smaller and I get more
information which is then maybe the
reverse if you want to say but the thing
is like I'm using that thing every day
oh you were actually going to a ski trip
to Lake Tahoe and you broke a finger or
your wrist or anything else and well
voila try to use your keyboard good luck
there are problems which everybody is
facing once
while in your life oh look at this
awesome event we have nice sunny weather
except for now when I'm looking outside
but well it'll come later today again
and then you're looking at your screen
outside you're trying to do something on
a notebook and you see screen glare and
you cannot see anything so what do you
do then well there is actually a feature
which actually might help you on that
and you might actually not be aware of
it coming to that one later so and then
there are other nice features like for
example the dictate feature which we
hurt or a something about in our in our
keynote and I think like this feature is
really totally awesome and I compare
that to 15 years ago I remember on a PC
I was like you have to train every
single time that until it finally
understood you no problem at all I'm
talking to that thing it transcribes
everything and really try it out it's
awesome and or do something like well
you want to actually do something while
you're working on something and well you
want to read out for example the latest
article for making years or something
like that while you're doing this so
it's another accessibility feature
because the thing is at that point time
you're reading the screen so with that
let's go into the features what we have
on Chrome OS and look at them one by one
what you have to do in order to make
these features happen and what we of
course doing to do so oh yeah there was
another slide look at that so we have
actually more form factor us well you
know of course the phone phone is this
kind of small device right but we have a
lot of big devices so we have we have
it's they come in all kinds of forms you
have tablets you have convertibles
clamshells
and then there's also boxes which means
like you have really like only an
external screen hooked up which is of
course giant which is awesome so make
use of the space so and there are
keyboards and all these other things
Chrome OS in a nutshell it's definitely
much more than on your phone so features
so one of the thing so the most
important feature I think is this one
which is chrome box which is it's reads
out loud what is on the screen it tells
the user exactly what is in a dialog in
a window and it's actually guiding the
user
through your dialog and this is a very
important feature and if there is any
feature what you have to really do to
your application to make accessible I
think supporting this one is really it
because things like this is addressing
90% of the problems and that is
essentially like for every label you
have know for every screen element you
actually add another label which is
giving you the talk what should actually
be talked with this way but Zara will
actually go more into depth later on in
our talk so yes so next one select -
speech I was mentioning that already
it's a great feature you can simply mark
something on the screen and the screen
reader will actually read everything to
you all out so what do you have to do in
order to support this thing well you
should actually have your text order and
groups in a certain way that it's
actually really readable but again Zahra
we'll talk about that one later in her
talk as well another feature is focus
highlighting there is something like I
mean UI designers they are really very
picky everything needs to be exactly the
color as I specify them and sometimes
there is really very nice but not really
very well distinguishable for people
which cannot really see these kind of
things and sometimes I even have the
problem of actually seeing what does
Rize focus or not so and this feature
for example gives you a much better
visible focus for all these kind of
elements when you're typing in something
you see for example around circle around
your your cursor and so on which makes
it much better visually so that you can
actually see this what do we have to do
in order to support this feature well
basically everything what you would
always do like for example all the UI
elements you want to use makes them that
they are on the screen so don't move
them out of the screen only that they
cannot be visible or something because
when you're all tap through them it
might actually come active and then you
don't even see what it is and or you
should also make sure that the order of
the items is actually in a proper order
that you can actually reach taps room
again sericata well if you talk about
that when they turn on me
so with that we have various features in
regards of how to magnify the screen to
make it better visible the first one is
a doctor
the docked sumo which is basically we
are taking apart one part of the screen
and it's actually the zoom it's like a
loop it's where you can actually see
then what is underneath occurs up so
this feature is very helpful you can
even zoom inside this area so you can
select the zoom factor you want to use
so what do you have to do in order to
support this thing well your application
should be better resizable and or at
least real layout will so that the
content is actually staying on the
screen another nice feature is this one
which is a full screen magnifier
basically the desktop everything stays
exactly as it is but there is only an
area of the screen like this which is
being shown to the user on the full
screen so and then when you're swiping
with your mouse over the screen you can
actually then reveal what is hidden in
the in the virtual area of the desktop
so and what do you have to do for this
feature nothing this is free of the
house we are doing that for you I hope
that helps
another thing is well we have the full
screen zoom factor which is basically we
are changing the density on the fly so
instead of seeing this with a teeny tiny
I could sell the bottom you can make
them much bigger and everything is
getting bigger which means bigger touch
targets bigger screen bigger phone we
get everything which means we are
changing the density what do you have to
do in order to support this feature well
it's a moment you should actually be it
resizable and you should actually listen
to density changes so going forward you
should definitely check out if the
density of your application is changing
and reacts and accordingly so when
you're using on configuration changes
make sure that you're reading them
accordingly so then there's a mouse the
mouse is something many people are
simply like hey where's my mouse well
shake it a little bit oh there this
because you can actually see the
movement but the problem is if you
cannot really see even the movement
because of course are still too small
there's no way to see that thing so
therefore we have a special feature
where you can actually increase the size
of the mouse column what do we have to
do for lose that for to support that
actually not very much in fact nothing
if you're using the standard Mouse
colors if you have a separate mouse
cursor however
you want to possibly add multiple
densities for this particular resource
because otherwise it might actually look
like the 80s was some kind of very jegi
lines outside which looks interesting
but maybe not that nice
so dictation feature well you simply
click into an input field you click on
the button for dictate and you type away
well talk away and what do you have to
do in order to support this feature
nothing comes free of the house you're
welcome it's awesome
another thing high contrast mode I was
mentioning it already if you go outside
Sun glare and whatnot you can actually
put the mode puts the screen into a
special mode which is actually making
improving the contrast what do we have
to do to support that thing nothing we
do everything for you you are done well
then there are many many more features
but the thing is for now let's stay with
that one and with that I'm passing it on
to Sarah great thanks Stefan so I'm
Sarah Cato I've come from Tokyo and I am
a software engineer working on
accessibility for Android applications
running on Chrome OS so you've just
heard from Stefan the importance of
accessibility as well as some of the
accessibility features that are
available on Chrome OS what I want to do
is to talk to you developers as to what
you can do in order to give the best
possible experience for users who are
using accessibility features to navigate
with and interact with your application
with Chrome OS users are going to want
to use the keyboard as a means of
navigating around the application by
moving focus and when you do so you need
to be aware of some of the subtle
details of how users are going to
interact with your application and
provide appropriate feedback to users
based on their interactions you might
know that since Chrome OS has been
launched it's been available in a number
of different form factors as Stefan just
mentioned to provide some examples this
includes the Samsung Dex
who are we desktop mode xiaomi sony OG
and the pixel slate devices and i'm sure
that you all
probably more than one type of laptop
more than one type of phone and across
these different devices you expect your
applications to work and users who use
accessibility features also expect the
same same experience and when the users
use Android applications on Chrome OS
they need to be able to accomplish
actions without the need to rely on a
mouse and you need to be able to cater
for this when users want to use the
keyboard to interact with your
application they are probably going to
use the tab key and with the screen
reader that Stephan just mentioned the
tab key is what you allows you to
navigate linearly using Chrome box users
can also choose to navigate through a
directional manner they can move in the
up down left and right direction and
they can achieve this using other
controls such as a directional pad also
known as a d-pad and in both of these
cases you need to take note of when
focus does not get applied correctly
some other types of input devices that
users may want to use are track pads or
switch for switch access and the types
of users who might be using these are
users would say mobility issues or
dexterity issues and they can find an
alternate means to provide input and
navigate around your application so I've
been talking a lot about focus but what
exactly is it it's when the widget is
highlighted to show you a change of
focus so you might be doing this when
you're navigating a spreadsheet for
example when you're navigating the
spreadsheet you would often use the
arrow keys to move between adjacent
cells and you'll see that the sole that
you're currently at is highlighted in
blue and you can also do the same in
your Android application however in your
Android application the order in which
focus is applied is determined by the
order in which the elements appear in
the layout or the XML and if you find
that in this case linear navigation or
even directional navigation doesn't work
in the way you expect it to
then you need to manually specify focus
and this is what I want to talk about
now the examples that I'm going to talk
about our going to be in Kotlin but you
should note that you'll be able to do
the same using Java and XML and I want
to show you how in order to make your
application more accessible
you don't need excessively excessive
code restructuring in addition to what
you've done already it's only a little
bit of extra code that you need to do in
order to really help some users the
first thing that I want you to do is to
set your widget to be focusable you can
do this by setting the set focusable
attribute to true once you've done that
on your wizard we can specify the
behavior for directional navigation and
as I just mentioned this is for users
who might be using a d-pad or trackball
and before this the system will provide
a best guess as to which view should
receive focus based on the direction of
the layout of the views of the screen
but to specify the order we can use the
set focus next set next focus attribute
and specify the direction that should
receive focus and provide the ID of the
widget that should receive focus and
something that I want you to know is
that if you fully support directional
navigation in your application it's
going to make testing much easier
because it's going to give you tools
such as the UI Automator and you will be
able to automate a lot of your UI
testing I also talked about linear
navigation using the tab key for the
coin box screenreader you can also
specify this behavior using the set next
focus forward and specifying the ID of
the widget in a similar manner I've
talked a lot about using the keyboard
and we often use the keyboard as a means
of convenience as well for example I'm
sure that you all use the Enter key
you might use the indicate to submit
forms or to send messages and this is
much easier than clicking the submit
button or finding the correct location
on the screen and accessibility users
also expect the same that would expect
the enter key to be able to provide them
with the same actions and us developers
you can also do this by setting a key
listener and I'm going to show you how
to add this behave
to your application you first start by
detecting that a key was pressed down
and you do this using the action art so
this actually tells you when you've
actually released the Enter key and
since we're using action up you might
think well is there an action down event
and there is and what is the difference
between these two well
the accent down returns multiple times
and this can be used for when you're
pressing the enter key for a long period
of time for example whereas the action
up only returns once so maybe when you
just hold the key down like in this
example once we've detected that we've
indeed press the key we can go on to
detect that it was actually the enter
key that was pressed and we can do this
by using the key event and specifying
that we want the enter key and you can
change the key event the key code of the
cabin and I'll show you how to do this
later so I've talked about using the
keyboard and how important it is for
Android applications to be able to be
accessible by the keyboard as they're
able to be run on Chrome OS and when
you're adding keyboard navigation you
should remember that users accessibility
users are going to expect comment
keyboard shortcuts such as undo and redo
to work so I'll show you what you can do
here a shortcut that you all probably
use every day I mean I know I use this
every day when I'm writing my code is
the undo action this interaction is the
keyboard shortcut is control Zen and
let's take a look at how we will do this
so I just talked about how you can use
the key code and now in this example
let's change the key code to be Zed
because we're looking for control Zed
once we've done that the control key is
a special key and we need to do
something that we call a me respect
check and this also applies to the alt
and the shift keys so once we've done
that we'll use the house modifies
function which returns true once this is
pressed and so now this example gives us
the ability to detect the ctrl z action
you can also combine multiple has
modifiers
so
in this example we have the control and
the shift key press down so this allows
us to detect the control or dead action
which you might all know as the redo
action so another really important
concept is grouping grouping is when
related content on your application is
organized into groups so that
accessibility services for example a
screen reader will be able to announce
the content in a way which would reflect
its natural groupings this means that
users won't need to swipe scan or wait
in order to define some other additional
information so let's think about who
these users might be these users might
be some blind people but my blind friend
for example or it might be those we'd
say temporal impairments like Stefan
mentioned maybe you're driving home from
IO today and you really want to use your
application but you got to keep your
eyes on the road so we can't view the
screen maybe it's for my grandparents
whose vision is deteriorating and they
need to use a screen reader to navigate
an application so I want to show you an
example of what grouping might be like
in an application so I have an
application here for a grocery store
that I want to go to this application
shows the grocery item as well as the
prices and let's just see what happens
if we don't specify any grouping at all
the screen reader might read out
something like this bread Oh J a dollar
fifty two dollars ninety nine as we've
just heard after hearing the item it
takes a while before we can hear the
price but what might a better example be
a better example might be the following
bread a dollar fifty Oh J two dollars 99
you can immediately hear the price of
bread which is a dollar fifty after its
announcement the same goes for AJ and
this makes such a big difference for
users who primarily rely on the screen
reader and you can do this with the
power of grouping
for this you would use an android screen
reader focusable attribute and this was
introduced in Android P and Android X
and is preferred over the Android
focusable attribute which had some
unwanted effects in regards to focus and
navigation for users who primarily
relied on the screen reader so in the
previous example for my grocery store
you would group the item as well as the
price into a single focusable container
so that the screen reader will be able
to present this information into a
single announcement and say that these
two items are related to each other this
means that users such as you such as my
blind friend such as my grandparents
will be able to understand that these
views are logically related to one
another another important concept that I
want to talk about is labeling so
labeling the purpose of this is to
explain the meaning of interactive
elements to users I mean I think you
often put labels on physical items in
everyday life just so you get a better
understanding of them this also makes
sense in the context of an Android
application this will by doing adding
correct labels screen readers such as
chrome box will be able to properly
explain the function of the UI widgets
in your applications to users and I also
think I can demonstrate this better with
an example so I have an application here
which is called choices cafe this
application allows you to order items
form job choices cafe and let's go and
look at how we structured this
application so you can see that I've
added some image buttons as well as the
ID and the source attribute everything
looks good right so now let's go and say
what a screen reader might read so I
have a friend his name is Rhys Rhys is
low vision and relies on the use of a
screen reader to navigate the
application and Risa's favorite food is
pizza he really really wants to order
pizza from Joyce's cafe so he turns on
his screen reader
and opens the application what is he
here immediately he is button hmm let's
see if there's anything else available
cerise presses tab he is button hmm okay
one last time I'm gonna press tap again
to see what else I can get presses tab
again button hmm
as you can see this type of navigation
doesn't really support users such as
base to navigate the application but
it's really easy for you to change this
and let's look at how we will do that
using labels so I have some image
buttons so we're going to use the
content description tag and you can see
here that for these content description
tags I've added the actual item that the
image button represents and the actual
attributes that you might use would
depend on the type of element that you
have but once I've added all my content
descriptions let's just see what the
screen reader would now read to Rhys so
race decides to give it one last shot
and opens the application again he
immediately he's chocolate okay not
really in the mood for chocolate now
let's see what else is available in
Joyce's cafe ill okay let's just hope
that he doesn't end up with this Pizza
awesome
Rhys is now able to order pizza his
favourite pizza from Joyce's cafe as you
can see just by adding content
descriptions made such a big difference
to users such as race so I've talked
about some simple views but if you have
some more complicated or custom views in
your application you might need some
additional work in order to make it more
accessible and the Android developer
documentation has more detail for on the
specific tasks that you might need to do
so with that I'll hand over to my
colleague Emily thanks Sarah my name is
Emily Roberts and I'm a developer
advocate with Chrome OS and what's my
next slide I forget okay there
we've been talking a lot about input and
keyboard and I think fundamentally and
what this talk is really about is how
users interact with and experience its
your applications and we're gonna talk a
little bit I'm gonna talk a little bit
about screens and layout which is near
and dear to my heart
and doing this right doing all of this
right can be the difference between a
user not being able to use your app at
all or at least being able to use it for
it to be convenient to use or to be
inconvenient to use and I think where we
all want to get is for your users to
find your app delightful to use natural
to use so whatever the service or
content they want is just that's the
choice for your app and I think that
applies for all users and for
accessibility users that's magnified so
I see some familiar faces some Chrome OS
fans and I've talked about some of this
stuff in my last talk it's just the
dress I wear when I talk about screens
and layout so that's why it's the same
dress if you ever see this dress you can
skip the talk no just kidding we have
some really great sand boxes around so
if you haven't seen your app on a Chrome
OS device uh check it out and see if
which category hopefully you're not in
the unusable category for accessibility
folks but hopefully you're in the
delightful and easy and natural and
that's where we want to go so we're
we're in the era of changing screens we
heard that in the keynote announcement
and in many of the sand boxes there's
phones tablets Chromebooks external
monitors foldables you name it and who
knows what's coming out this year and
next year the app world is changing and
you really want your apps to just work
seamlessly across all of these devices
in a big way oh wait I got to tell you
my story I wrote this on the side so I
want to talk about my mom cuz I bought
her a pixel book and there's so many
Android apps she would never think of
using on her phone and my mom has pretty
good vision she's very able and just
having it on a larger screen makes it so
much more delightful and easier to
engage with and for many accessibility
users using an external monitor can be
life-changing or using a not
life-changing but in a completely
enabling
using a screen reader can mean your app
can be used cool so for many
applications this is about layout and
screen size and the easiest way to do
this or a really great way in my opinion
to do this is to have different layout
buckets for different screen sizes in
this case I'm using width so for a large
landscape or a large portrait I might
have a different layout versus a mobile
phone portrait or landscape you know six
eight two layouts depending on what your
UI looks like in the codelab tent we
have a resizing code lab which can help
you with this my focus on my team this
year has been looking at navigation
patterns for large screens especially as
we see foldable devices and chromo more
external monitors happening and of
course a growing range of Chromebooks
and they're very closely related to
screen layout but it's a I think it
deserves its own separate topic so
imagine you have a mobile phone
application designed for narrow portrait
screens and you plug in an external
monitor to see what that looks like and
it looks horrible
it looks terrible and the designer
should go back to design school I'm
recycling my joke from yesterday so
throw her out of the room she's horrible
look at that stretched out screen this
is a photo viewer by the way so maybe on
a phone it makes sense if you have a
hundred photos not to try to show 100
previews on a phone screen but on an
external monitor come on we can do
better than that and what I think is
specifically important for many users
with accessibility is the navigation
along the bottom here's the bottom
navigation it's all stretched out the
icons are tiny and they're just in this
vast sea of space so even if you're
eagle-eyed and have excellent dexterity
it's very difficult to see to understand
and to interact with these elements and
you can imagine it being literally
impossible for some people okay I was
the designer give me a second chance I
did a better job I've included a photo
preview on the side I made a little bit
better use of the screen realist
this is like moving in the direction of
making my app easy and delightful
convenient to use I've done a little bit
better in the middle column and most
importantly take a look at the
navigation on the left side navigation
there's labels there's icons they're
visible and they're all grouped nicely
together so I can easily go from one to
the other without having just to search
around on the screen oh I got to go back
this live about 30 minutes ago this
beautiful amazing photo viewing sample
is available on github for your perusal
it's just a little demo it's not that
amazing but check it out okie dokie more
information is available on the material
design site they have a number of
material studies a number of case
studies that you can look at this is the
reply app and they're doing just this so
for different layouts depending on the
screen size you're looking at in the
first example with the long stretched
out bottom navigation the targets were
very small hard to see and hard to
interact with especially for someone
with any dexterity needs we recommend a
minimum touch target size of 48 DP
that's not new hopefully you all know
that but it's super-important for all
the reasons I've just outlined you can
also use constraint layout and allow it
to scale up naturally using percentages
and make it easier to squish those
little pink aliens here's just a quick
example a little bit exaggerated but on
a portrait mobile phone why not have the
icons visible and easy to interact with
and clear I don't have a lot of time
left
but I just want to give a big shout out
to view model and navigation and jetpack
as a whole if you haven't been using it
check out their sandbox and the code
labs and their talks and the
documentation it's awesome as an Android
developer my main pain points have just
like disappeared with it when you're
handling different screen layouts view
model makes state so elegant and easy to
just maintain you don't have to worry
about if you're resizing on a chrome OS
app and you're getting 20 configuration
changes
this is real and it goes up and down it
can be a hundred configuration changes
it's hard to handle all by yourself
the views view model done finished
finished navigation if you're working
with all those different navigation
patterns fragments can be a headache
popping the stack and if you have a
fragment in a fragment and a fragment if
you know what I'm talking about
it's super hard navigation makes that a
lot easy d Android comm slash jetpack
check it out I'm gonna take the last
couple seconds just to call it something
unique to chromeboxes a special aren't
Chromebooks let me say it again it's not
necessarily unique to chrome Chrome OS
because lots of phones these days are
supporting desktop mon-sol it's in the
Android QAPI is Huawei Samsung LG I
believe all have desktop modes plugging
external monitors into your Android
devices on Chrome OS this is even easier
and much more common and with chrome
boxes sorry I should say with chrome
boxes it's is required there's no other
screen so we can have up to seven
external monitors for the most part you
don't have to do anything your apps will
just work and the users can move them
around if you check out the live or
sorry the recorded version of our talk
Stephan went into a bit more detail
about how density works but if you just
want to do something with your
activities you can get a look at the
number of displays connected to your
system using the display manager and
then if you want an activity to appear
on a specific display you can use launch
display ID and pop it over there okay
couple last mentions we have a couple of
code labs one is on resizing one is on
optimizing input for Chrome OS devices
so that's keyboard mouse drag and drop
all that great stuff
these have been refreshed for 2019
accessibility has their own code lab
which goes a lot more into detail with
grouping and labeling and this is also
had a nice refresh for 2019 check that
out in the code lab tense as I mentioned
there are some great sandboxes the
accessibility and material design
sandbox is over there over there it's
close by
so check that out as well as our Chrome
OS sandbox is where you can try out
first of all your applications and see
where you fall on the scale of unusable
convenient and amazing hopefully towards
the AE side the amazing side and you can
also look at developing your apps right
on Chromebooks for web for game for
Android which is also pretty cool
and don't forget while you're there to
collect your really cool chrome OS
enamel pins we have seven of them with
the secret eighth one which I don't know
if I'm supposed to mention but collect
them around at the Android sandbox at
the Chrome OS sandbox at the gaming
sandbox code labs and our office hours
with that it's about time to say goodbye
I think accessibility matters and you
should implement it because it's the
right thing to do period at the same
time it enables all users for all the
cases we've been talking about including
yourself
it makes your app much much more easier
to use much more delightful to engage
with better to engage with so we have
more users more enabled users more happy
users more empowered users and that's
the some of my talk I want to say if you
take three things away from this support
keyboard think about your layouts and
navigation and most importantly add
labels and group into your app adding
labels and grouping can go a really long
way way to enable os's to then do
intelligent things with your apps and
make them available to lots and lots of
users so I'd like to thank you for your
time this morning and building awesome
apps thinking about Chrome OS and all
this stuff and your energy here and also
to thank Sarah and I found my fellow
co-presenters have a wonderful last day
of i/o enjoy it thanks a lot
[Applause]
[Music]
you